meilleur élève j'ai envie de dire genton
aujourd'hui j'entends c'est une
révélation pour moi un vrai aussi aussi
est moins bon élève bonne tout de suite
non moins bons élèves on élève j'ai
envie de dire parce que j'aime pas sa
tête c'est gilles verdez tu viens d
ouais mais c'est totalement de mercy non
mais vous avez bien argumenté voilà ça
fait vous quelqu'un de bien wespiser
vous dire vous même c'est moi meilleur
élève je vais dire comme benjamin c'est
guillaume gens travaillent je trouve
qu'il est hyper pertinent dans tout ce
qui dit il est au coeur il est au coeur
du sujet donc forcément et moins bons
élèves
je vais dire mon voisin ici parce que il
s'est beaucoup énervé cette saison moi
j'aime bien quand il un peu plus calme a
énervé il était très énervé vous n'aimez
pas ça gueule également non aussi of
papua or pas fou pas fou non la fouta
fou nicolas pernikoff alors pour moi
l'art pub je vous réserve c'est un peu
compliqué mais le meilleur élève pour
moi c'est gilles verdez qui est une
vraie révélation pour son retour pour
qu'il est beaucoup plus calme et qu'il
est extrêmement pertinent et j'ai
beaucoup de j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et
d'admiration pour lui parce que je
trouve qu'il a une prise de parole
facile et qu' il est souvent très
pertinent mois d'avril et le moins bon
élève il faut le dire peut-être moi en
fait
franchement je ne suis pas à l'aise donc
non je vous dirais moi parce que j'ai
rien à gérer n'est reproché à quiconque
à cette table donc je trouve que tout le
monde est bon quand on sait pas on
démonte y est
andy murray s'est créé une bonne équipe
c'est une équipe c'est une super idée
alors meilleurs élèves pour moi c'est
chez g pour moi ça a toujours été une
des meilleures élèves français pas un
honneur venant de ma part mais en tout
cas pour moi tu étais une des meilleures
et plus mauvaise élève c'est bernard
montiel mais vraiment sans hésiter suce
boules de la terre n'importe quoi je
sais pas quoi dire sort des mots qui
sortent nulle part de son cerveau les
insupportables gym c'est vraiment le
plus nul mais pourquoi parce que ça
s'est mal passé tout à l'heure en loge
mais voulait mais quand même mais je les
adore en tout cas ça soit vous savez
recevoir vos habits non mais vraiment
c'est qu'il est bon je suis honnête avec
mes amis nathalie marquay alors pour moi
c'est gilles verdez le meilleur oui et
non parce que la touche aussi les bonnes
infos il est percutant et
il n'a pas sa langue dans sa poche et il
y va c'est bon et le moins bon élève et
ben c'est moi vraiment et bah si si si
c'est moi je suis la moins expérimentée
même sauf que c'est moi franchement
c'est fou ça voyez pas là franchement
sachez que des anciens jamais un ancien
se désignera lui-même verte est pour moi
la meilleure elle survole l'année c'est
kelly kelly parce que quand elle parle
la lumière arrive pas ok c'est bon avec
fatou lui parce qu'elle a des arguments
pertinents parce que son cadre et ses
tubes
non non je trouve voilà qu'elle est
excellente et dès qu'elle est là c'est
différent donc c'est kelly et qu'elle
est tu le crois qu'il vient de dire mais
on a un truc gilles et moi ah bon jaloux
non loin d'aix est loin d'être sexuelle
et on veut pas le savoir
isabelle au gilles verdez le pire oui
c'est montiel franchement cyril vous
adore mais comment faites vous pour le
faire venir chaque soir j'adore bernard
baude chef de la junte le dax est montée
jusqu'au oui mais c'est le roi des
branleurs il va travaille jamais il
arrive il ne sait même pas ce qu'il va
dire oui c'est le vide incarner c'est le
pire il avait alors moi le meilleur
c'est guillaume genton est le pechoux
elle aussi je suis même pas je suis pas
d'accord avec lui et ça arrive souvent
le trouve toujours pertinent étayé est
toujours calme d'accord qu'elle m'a
contrario parce que je vais pas me
désigner moi même parce que vous savez
pas que des fois j'ai des trucs à dire
mais donc pour moi le pire c'est gilles
parce qu'il est toujours surexcité et
3000 à côté ça me gonfle que toujours
jeunes téléspectateurs et 2h13
enfin conseil de classe à dallas fois
qu'on a fait un conseil de classe on a
perdu deux chroniqueurs à 2/4 cyber bien
que va-t-il se passer
qu'est-ce qu'a et de coeur c'est bernard
l'accord merci bernard monte alors pour
moi la meilleure élève c'est vraiment
guillaume genton d'accord il est
vraiment très bon il parle très très
bien il est très clair c'est vrai que
c'est souvent les nouveaux les meilleurs
élèves
il est très bien les très clair il faut
le garder et
vous croyez qu'on vous écoute c'est pour
ça que je dis qu'on m'écoute et le plus
mauvais alors j'ai lire moi je travaille
énormément mais j'arrive pas à en placer
une
donc c'est toujours un peu difficile cc
regarder je travaille mais bon je trouve
que le toujours les autres s'expriment
mieux que moi donc je n'ose pas y aller
c'est vrai on sait qu'elle plus mauvais
et même mois non non vous pouvez pas
dire ça va sinon moi j'ai du charme agit
du charme mais ça n'a rien à voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors le meilleur pour moi de loin j'ai
eu déjà dit c'est guillaume genton
trouve qu'il s'est imposé d'une manière
fulgurante
je trouve posée pertinent à
contre-courant il a un très très bon
débit par bien il est charismatique il
est plutôt stylée même si c'est souvent
ridicules a vraiment une très très très
belle recrue est le pire pour sa voisine
jeter et parce qu'il me fait mourir de
rire à toutes les émissions que c'est
très très compliqué de contenir les fous
rires c'est bernard montiel
ouais ça aurait fait rire mais c'est
juste extraordinaire en tout cas il y en
a vraiment d'eux qui ressort pour deux
qualités complètement différente un mois
la meilleure élève c'est delphine c'est
une très belle période et le monde a
rêvé haut et on n'est pas là pour tous
ces professionnels mais ça n'a pas la
professionnelle et le pire je sais pas
quoi dire dont je veux dire montiel
passé à c'est gratos et maintiennent
quel [ __ ] je retire ce que j'ai dit
vous avez vu un pur pour les
chroniqueurs le meilleur chroniqueur
c'est gai ou jean thomas et le moins bon
c'est pas ma faute et je vais demander
aux twittos steunou donnait également
meilleurs éléments prenons milliard
seulement pas courts les tweets moi bon
on va pas donner moi juste le meilleur
voilà je vous dirais alors c'est nicolas
pernikoff pour moi le meilleur non alors
moi pour moi le meilleur
franchement oui c'est gilles va de
chouilly je dis la vérité
oui j'adore rio mais pour moi c'est
bernard angulaire angulaire et benjamin
cegid vigilant c'est benjamin
mais voilà alors blake se disent je n'ai
pas de préférence jauzion c'est comme si
vous demandez de choisir entre mes
enfants je vous jure que c'est vrai je
vous aime tous pour des qualités
différentes mais je vous aime tous je
trouve fait un très bon travail cette
année tous non et je vous jure que c'est
pas une bombe à gauche que j je le pense
vraiment pense vraiment je trouve c'est
une bonne équipe cette année voilà je
vous aime tous voilà et isabelle bien
sûr c'est ma petite chouchoute parce que
pierre je sais que chaque jour de prix
est important
[Rires]